we were starting to get ready for this
new show i wanted to start completely
fresh
new studio new desk new guest couch new
look
i even held and people don't know this i
held auditions for new staff positions
and i think we have one of those
audition tapes let's take a look
okay next please
thank your name please are you really
gonna do this please state your name
andy richter okay and you're interested
in being a sidekick and announcer on the
show
yes i'm interested in being a sidekick
and announcer on the show
okay what do you think qualifies you for
this job why are you doing this
just answer the question please um
previous experience you've had previous
experience yes i had previous experience
can you tell us where you worked
that was the answer on the tonight show
with kevin o'brien do you have tape of
that
no no one does okay
tonight george clooney angelina jolie
i'm gonna stop you right there uh we
can't get guests like that
i'm sorry that was my mistake that would
never happen um
more realistic please okay uh
bob vela
really no megan fox is on the show
i'm flirting with her i growl wow
all right uh what's your reaction
like kind of skeeved out okay
what i need you to do is act like oh oh
oh
oh boy there's real sexual chemistry
here
um yeah yeah you can't act
out you're not like man that guy is
obviously straight
it's your job to support me it's your
job to really sell the joke
so i tell really funny joke and bang
okay can you try without the head shake
because that seems like you're saying no
what's trying to get a funny joke and
bang
this feels like you're clearing
something out of your chest how about a
funny joke and bang
i actually think that could work
i wish you would really do that in the
monologue i'm saving it for the
christmas show